Traduttore: Lisa Meschi
Revisore: Sylvia Mondinelli
Il Museo di Arte Contemporanea di Bolzano,
dove ci troviamo,
è dotato di una facciata mediale
pensata dagli architetti
affinché su questa superficie possano
essere proiettati i contenuti del museo
dopo gli orari di chiusura.
Io la considero uno spazio in between,
uno spazio tra un dentro e un fuori,
da attraversare e da analizzare.
Anche la mia figura professionale
di curatrice
si trova spesso a operare
in uno spazio in between
tra l'artista, il pubblico
e il contesto museale o della città.
Ma ci sono molti artisti che prendono
proprio lo space in between
come oggetto della loro pratica artistica
e che lo indagano in diversi modi.
Io volevo riferirmi in particolare
a Vera Comploj,
che è un'artista che è presente
nella collezione di Museion
con una serie fotografica che si intitola
proprio "In Between" ed è del 2010.
In questi scatti, Vera ha fatto vedere
lo space in between
tra il camerino ed il palcoscenico
delle bellissime Drag Queen di New York,
lo space in between che abitano
tra il pubblico e il palcoscenico
e tra il trucco che stanno mettendo
e il personaggio che stanno lasciando.
E anche la stessa Vera ha assunto,
come posizione,
proprio con la sua macchina fotografica,
lo space in between,
come si può vedere dagli scatti
che qui scorrono.
Dunque, lo space in between è
una sorta di spazio ricco di aspettative,
ricco di un prima e di un dopo,
ricco di un desiderio,
nel caso appunto delle Drag Queen.
Ma è anche uno spazio di trasformazione
e questo mi fa pensare, per esempio,
agli attori quando devono diventare
un personaggio per una parte.
Ci sono tantissimi esercizi che in teatro
si utilizzano per impersonare un attore;
io faccio riferimento in particolare
a uno che si chiama
"Il cerchio neutro".
Cosa avviene?
L'attore si posiziona all'interno
di un cerchio, proprio al suo centro,
disegnato per terra.
Si deve svuotare della propria personalità
e accogliere mano a mano
il personaggio che deve impersonificare,
il ruolo che deve essere
per quella determinata parte.
Mano a mano
che avviene questa trasformazione,
lo spazio, la circonferenza
disegnata a terra
si ingrandisce sempre di più
fino a occupare il palcoscenico
e idealmente il mondo.
Faccio riferimento
a questo esercizio del teatro
perché mi serve per spieare cos'è per me,
per definire lo space in between,
che è uno spazio di trasformazione,
che è uno spazio
che diventa ricettacolo di possibilità,
come la facciata mediale pensata
dagli architetti per questo edificio.
Infatti ecco qui un dettaglio fotografico
dell'architettura.
Lo space in between, la facciata
tra il museo e la città,
tra il fuori e il dentro.
Uno spazio da attraversare
con il corpo, con l'immaginazione.
Ma non a caso parlo di corpo,
perché dal 2014,
nel pensare alla programmazione
della facciata mediale,
ho iniziato una collaborazione
col festival di Bolzano Danza.
E dunque nel 2014 abbiamo iniziato
con il progetto Venerdì Robinson
dell'artista Luca Trevisani
e del collettivo MK.
Il titolo "Venerdì Robinson"
parte da un romanzo di Michel Tournier
intitolato
"Venerdì o il limbo del Pacifico".
Limbo, 'spazio tra'.
Robinson, il personaggio di Tournier,
infatti incontrava in questo 'spazio tra'
prima la natura, poi Venerdì,
e successivamente incontrava se stesso.
Ed era quello che un po' hanno fatto
i visitatori di Museion
per questo progetto
perché prima incontravano
le immagini proiettate sulla facciata
e sentivano la musica
che si sprigionava dall'edificio,
successivamente incontravano
gli elementi scenici
che erano posti all'interno del museo
e proiettati live sulla facciata.
E incontravano anche il volto
di uno dei danzatori
che rappresentava un po'
l'elemento esotico.
Infine, il pubblico incontrava la danza,
dislocata in diversi luoghi dell'edificio.
Il pubblico, lo sguardo del pubblico
era dunque un continuo passaggio
tra un dentro e un fuori,
un attraversamento di luoghi
che ricalcava così lo sguardo di Robinson
proprio nel romanzo di Tournier.
L'anno successivo, Riccardo Benassi
e la coreografa danzatrice Cristina Rizzo
invece sono approdati qui con
Techno Casa Plus.
Techno Casa Plus è un progetto
che vede la facciata mediale
come uno degli elementi di questa
grande installazione performativa
che durava un'ora e mezza.
Il progetto era un continuo parallelismo
tra la casa, l'ambito privato,
che si smaterializza sempre di più
con l'irrompere dei dispositivi digitali,
Techno Casa,
e il mondo del fitness, che prevede
un'ossessione per l'empowerment del corpo.
Ecco perché l'aggettivo "plus"
abbinato a "Techno casa".
In una traccia sonora
che durava un'ora e mezza,
cinque danzatori danzavano incessantemente
dentro il museo,
prendendo
all'interno della loro coreografia
anche dei gesti di uso quotidiano,
come quello di usare gli attrezzi ginnici
che erano dentro il museo,
quello di assumere bevande energizzanti,
oppure quello di interagire
con i dispositivi digitali
che erano smartphone o touch screen.
E al pubblico cosa succedeva?
Il pubblico era invitato
ad attraversare questo spazio
in un tempo che diventava dilatato
e anche lo spazio, uno spazio trasformato,
e interagire con questa installazione,
con il corpo dei danzatori
e infine anche a liberarsi,
in un certo qual modo,
e diventare esso stesso corpo danzante
all'interno di questo spazio.
Vi parlavo prima di immaginazione,
ma forse serve anche un po' di coraggio,
ed ecco quindi il progetto
"Mut for love", coraggio per l'amore,
un progetto ideato da uno studio grafico,
Studio Mut,
che è avvenuto l'anno scorso
e che ha visto questo space in between,
dunque la facciata,
essere al centro di una relazione.
La relazione era tra una persona,
un oggetto d'amore e una comunità,
proprio perché Studio Mut aveva creato
un sito internet,
www.mutforlove.com,
in cui invitava tutti quanti a mandare
delle lettere d'amore, delle poesie,
e anche
delle dichiarazioni di matrimonio,
tutto in maniera anonima,
come avviene nelle dichiarazioni.
E loro ne hanno selezionati sette
per creare sette storie,
per creare sette scenari,
un po' ammiccando
ai sette giorni della creazione.
Dunque sulla facciata mediale
sono comparse queste sette storie d'amore
ponendo appunto, come vi dicevo prima,
la facciata
all'interno di questo triangolo.
Una sorta di dichiarazione d'amore
alla città di Bolzano.
Ma cosa avverrà quest'estate
sulla nostra facciata mediale?
Quello che immagino è che,
come vi dicevo prima
per quanto riguarda il cerchio neutro,
mi immagino che questo perimetro
a un certo punto scompaia,
ci sia uno sconfinamento,
e ci sia un abbraccio della città.
E quindi per sconfinare
ho pensato a una dinamica
che è quella tra video storici
di artisti degli anni '30, '60 e '70
proiettati appunto sulla facciata
e musicati da degli artisti,
dei compositori contemporanei
invitati a performare live
davanti a questa facciata,
proprio per abbracciare ancora di più
la città e chi la abita.
La facciata mediale di Museion quindi
è uno dei tantissimi esempi
di come l'arte lavori sul confine,
lo lavora, lo analizza
da diversi punti di vista
e lo trasforma in uno spazio
di creatività,
di opportunità di crescita,
ma soprattutto di incontro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)